because I know maybe it's the the
stereotypical logical thinking do you
think if a man's ready to build a legacy
then he understands that's the sacrifice
he's willing to make it is a sacrifice
giving up my freedom is a big suffer
sacrifice investing that much emotional
energy time attention to someone is a
massive sacrifice you better be the real
deal I can't afford to do that and even
legally like men are at such a
disadvantage in the laws today so that's
why earlier when you were talking about
how men gain more from Marriage they get
they gain the risk to that you can leave
take half and the kids leverage your
kids against you get more rights in this
country that's a fact yeah
you're going to be you're going to be
like lit serious like
um I mean when thinking of it as a
sacrifice as opposed to an investment
like
said thinking of it as a sacrifice as
opposed to an investment like it's both
okay cool but that's that's what that's
that's one more of that's what
investment is though you sacrifice some
funds to invest in something that those
that's time energy attention I could be
spending elsewhere but I choose this one
person that that's that's like uh and
now they have and now they have the risk
so they're they have the risk that you
could leave and take half you might not
do it and you might assume that like you
might think that you won't but there's a
50 chance
that the marriage ends in divorce and
it's a 70 to 80 chance that the woman
leaves 90 chance if you're college
educated so from a dude's point of view
like that is a huge risk why do you in
your eyes why do you see marriages more
of a benefit for the man than the woman
mainly because most men
when you get married I think it makes
life more stable you're able to focus
more you're able to yeah basically just
focus more can you not do that with a
relationship without marriage
um maybe but then I think the fact that
the woman is more likely to leave
they don't I mean to be honest
essentially things are all complaining
about how bad marriage or how it's not
good and how women are like this and how
certain women don't deserve this then
just don't get mad no okay I think I
think all this stuff
about the reality of what comes with
marriage today especially for men right
that's what we're saying but do you find
it interesting how like she did she
doesn't recognize the sacrifice for men
I do recognize that's a lot of women who
just don't but I think I don't get it
but I think I think a big part of that
though is because I don't think women
have the same appetite for variety that
men do so when so when a man if a man
grows accustomed to having a variety it
is a sacrifice for him I mean because
the guy who doesn't have rights is not a
sacrifice for him like the relationship
is only a bonnet it's only a bonus I
agree with that yeah if a man is married
do you think he's entitled the sex
with his wife yeah yeah of course why
not do you think if she's not giving it
him sex that he can cheat
no I don't think if she's not giving do
you see sex as a duty from the wife
it's a duty for both of them yeah it's
part of like it's part of married life
to have sex with your husband I'm
considering but considering that's
predominantly the woman's value if a man
isn't so for example a man says I
require so I'm providing everything but
I can't just be any bloke you're married
he's providing absolutely everything he
says I want sex four times a day you say
no do you believe if you can't hack that
he should be able to explore that sexual
uh desire elsewhere if you're not
satisfied him when he's satisfying you
with all of his resources time and
energy and provision if you as a woman
if it doesn't bother you as a woman that
your husband is going to step out and
cheat then call him cheat okay the thing
is you're now giving him every reason to
step out and cheat like I'm not saying a
woman should have sex with a man but
don't you want to have sex with your man
four times a day yes hello let's be
honest like let's be honest he's doing
everything for you he's doing everything
literally you've asked for you what I
wanted well then it's like modern woman
you shop they show up to their jobs when
they don't want to but they won't show
up to their husbands when they don't
want to this is why this is what I say
you want to have your cake in a year I
think the man at that stage if he's if
he's again he has to be providing
everything can't just be bumming around
doing [ __ ] all yeah he's providing
everything that's his value to you right
the provision okay naturally if the
value for a man from you is the is sex
and you're not fulfilling that desire
the way you're being fulfilled uh from
your desire him do you believe that he
is he should be able to conversation
it's like um and I think marriage looks
different for everybody to be honest so
I think that's a cop-out I personally
think that's a copper I think when you
say marriage looks different for
everybody in what sense in the sense
that okay I'm thinking about like Will
Smith and Jada they've re-negotiated and
rearranged their marriage
Will Smith when you say they're
renegotiating what you're actually
saying is Will Smith trying to attempt
to grow up here to be
honestly I agree I agree
I feel like you guys
it's okay it doesn't matter but I can
imagine because Will Smith gives
everything he gives his Fame he gives
his time he forgives it for whatever she
does yeah but she doesn't she doesn't
listen
he worships her she says oh I I kind of
I Still Love Tupac um and I settled for
you and he goes well well marriage for
life you know yeah you know I think um I
think you would love that I think that's
what you mean because you don't know me
that's very that very man that very man
who
the man you just described Will Smith
the man who who bends over backwards he
gives you everything and you you have no
respect for him that there is a
picture-perfect example of the man who
would take on a woman at 40 years old
with 12 kids wait so so were you saying
they were a good example I didn't think
you were yeah yeah I was I was trying to
say that the way that they have
basically
define marriage how they want to Define
it right that they can have an they've
agreed to have an open marriage and
they're entitled to you that's that's a
great prior I'm talking if the
relationship the presumption when you
start a relationship like any or the
marriage story was like any other
marriage in the western world or
relationship in the Western World which
is we are together there's going to be
no cheating he provides everything she
doesn't give him the sex or sexually
satisfying does he have the right to go
and cheat with the presumption in the
beginning that they are monogamous do
you know I think okay in if I was to get
because I can't talk about anybody else
but myself if I was married and my
husband wanted more of me than I could
give I would hope that we had a good
enough relationship for me and him to
sit down and for us to discuss options
if that meant a threesome bringing other
women in then I would be down for it you
know what I respect that answer okay
[Music]
okay so
um I think we're gonna close out the
show
um why don't we go around everyone say
your final thoughts and if anyone has a
super chat they want me to read um send
it now while they're giving final
thoughts and I'll read them before we
finish the bigger number you send the
quicker she'll read it thank you okay so
if you want to think then why don't we
start with Jordan and go around so I
would say ultimately
learn to understand what it is men and
women want from a surface level and a
biological standpoint
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible